you know I don't really get upset about
Oscar snubs anymore because I mean it's
the Oscars but I was a little sad to
hear that Shawn Baker's the Florida
Project didn't make the cut for Best
Picture this year because I think when
it comes to the Academy Awards the
nominations really matter more than who
the eventual winner is it's always silly
to pick the best anything when it comes
to art but with the nominations at least
the 7,000 members of the Academy get a
chance to highlight a field of diverse
transformative films
[Applause]
if the Oscars won't highlight the
Florida project then I'm happy too
because it's without a doubt one of the
best films of 2017 and watching it for
me was one of those transporting
experiences that I only get a few times
a year if at all the story is about a
group of kids and their parents who live
in a budget motel outside of Disney
World in Florida the people who live in
this community are on the economic
margins not quite homeless but not quite
able to keep a permanent roof over their
heads either the struggles of living in
this kind of poverty give the film an
undertone of sadness but the genius of
the Florida project is that it tells its
story from the perspective of the
children who can't help but see their
world as a playground maker is bullying
heavily from Hal Roach's Little Rascals
a classic series of comedy short films
from the 20s and 30s that was
groundbreaking in the way that it showed
kids as well kids trying to capture the
nuances of their behavior and energy in
a naturalistic way like the Florida
Project Rascals was set against economic
hardship the Great Depression these kids
too were growing up in poverty but the
focus was never on that it was on the
scrappy optimism of childhood now the
Florida Project has deeper ambitions
than Rascals but that optimism the
brightness of this point of view is
everything it keeps the subject-matter
from being too overwhelming something
that can shut down our ability to
empathize and sympathize Shaun Baker I
think understands something really
critical about storytelling that we
don't absorb things by looking directly
at them often we see more clearly
through indirect means
there's a lot that Baker and co-writer
crisper gosh want to say about the
hidden homeless in America but they
don't just come right out and say it or
show it the reality of these troubled
lives exists in the peripheral vision of
a child's day baker and a
cinematographer alexis sabe keep the
camera low parents are often framed
peanut style just a bunch of legs even
when the kids aren't around they favor
low angles so that adults tower over the
frames and through the course of the
film you remember what it's like to see
the world from such a low angle you
remember how big everything seemed and
how much sky there actually is carefully
building this perspective pays off in a
scene like this where you have a key
piece of information about these
people's lives which is that they
struggle so much to make their bills
that they need the assistance of a local
church Food Bank Baker plays the scene
again from young Muniz perspective and
we have to piece together what's really
happening here he doesn't want to show
us the food assistance itself he wants
to show us how normal something like
that is to Mooney that's the devastating
thing in fact all of the film's most
crushing moments are played from the
perspective of kids when Muniz mother
starts prostituting herself to make rent
this is the way that the Florida project
shows us
[Music]
this is how the film talks to us
something has always seen through
something else the decaying edge lands
outside Disney World are seen through
the colourful imagination of an
adventurous kid the promise of Disney
World is seen through the poverty that
surrounds it the pain of living without
work is seen through the kindness of
neighbors and strangers and motel
managers and Mooney and her mother
Hayley the film's two main characters
are seen through each other in some ways
Hayley is a loving caring mother and
others she's a delinquent selfish mother
these are all things that we see and
learn through the way that Mooney acts
in Hayley we see a Mooney that was a
child that grew out of her innocence and
we also see a Mooney that might be it's
in the continuum of these two that the
film finds a way to express truths that
are larger than the movie itself for
those living in the margins of late
capitalism tossed around by the wave of
the Great Recession Mooney and Hayley
are representative of a cycle of
hardship that can lock itself into a
family tree for decades mothers like
Hayley bear some of the responsibility
for the situation but we bear some of
the responsibility too because as the
film shows us mothers like Hayley really
just kids like Mooney and Mooney is
nothing but innocent it's a way of
understanding the individual and
societal responsibilities for poverty
that only a film can achieve and only a
film with this kind of discipline now
this doesn't mean that the Florida
Project is trying to Trojan horse a sad
story to the viewer it's an incredibly
joyous movie it's fun to watch like the
little rascals and the particular
heartbreak we feel doesn't and can't
exist without that joy Baker couldn't
express one without expressing the other
because he understands that they're part
of the same thing that's the kind of
understanding and this is the kind of
filmmaking Academy members should
promote through their nominations it's a
shame they didn't but I guess I
shouldn't mind about
because I mean it's the Oscars hey
everybody
happy Wednesday thank you so much for
watching this episode was brought to you
by Verve if you don't know Verve is a
service that that pulls together a lot
of great content channels like
roosterteeth mondo crunchyroll
Funimation to watch all in one place so
you can see some of the best anime there
definitely but they've also added a lot
of new channels like Mubi which hosts a
rotating roster of 30 indie movies which
is something that I love one other show
that I would personally like to
recommend is the director's chair where
director Robert Rodriguez interviews
other directors like Coppola George
Miller Guillermo del Toro I've been
looking for somewhere to watch these
episodes for so long so I'm thrilled
that Verve has it now
you can only watch that with Verve
premium which gives you ad free access
to everything all 13 channels and for a
limited time you can use the first link
in the description to get a 30-day free
trial of Verve so definitely try that
out oh and they have offline mode now
too so you can watch all that awesome
stuff on the go without an internet
connection which is pretty cool thanks
again guys I'll see you next time